hey y'all
look what we're talking about today
texas chainsaw massacre
two two because we already did the first
one that's why you said y'all right
yeah yeah trying to take
try to take you down to texas for this
one so i've never seen this movie
yeah you thought you'd seen it but you
hadn't i saw it i was going damn why
didn't i [ __ ] see this movie back
then i would have liked it even more i
mean i liked it
it was kind of like evil dead one and
two and the tone was right
yeah skinny puppy sampled the hell out
of it and their [ __ ] music and their
songs you know what i mean and i
i had seen scenes but yeah i never seen
the whole thing
i just thought i did this movie is
batshit crazy yeah
i remember the first time i saw this i
think i was at
a slumber party and we rented it i must
have been 15 or so
and we rented it and we just thought we
we'd seen the first one obviously this
one
is much much different than the first
texas chainsaw massacre even though
it was also directed by toby hooper and
i feel like
less so nowadays but i think when it
first came out in 1986
i feel like it was real divisive like
among horror fans
well just because it's a completely
different tone
than the first movie it's almost like a
parody of the first movie
you know what i mean and i think like
some people didn't like that i can kind
of see what you're talking about but it
wasn't
a parody of the first movie say in the
way that you know
escape from l.a was versus escape from
new york
that went from [ __ ] awesome to like
what the [ __ ] is it
this year it's the same tone that you
saw with evil dead one and two
uh you'd recognize it in modern term in
in the modern
i guess what he called it in the modern
gestalt you'd probably say it was kind
of like
devil's rejects and house of a thousand
corpses you can really see where those
but funnier and more over the top yeah
but
more ridiculous i mean i guess those are
ridiculous too but that's where rob
zombie i think got the idea from because
we were talking about bill mosley and
stuff like that too
yeah but you know here's the thing i
kind of like this tone in horror i find
it a lot more
that's why i'm amazed that you didn't
see this yeah because this is right up
your alley
i like this tone a lot better i think
it's it makes the uh
i guess you could say you don't have to
suspend your disbelief
because the tone is not one of realism
yeah
but it's also to me disturbing
but in the way that yeah thousand
corpses because they're kind of making
fun of
people suffering and [ __ ] which i always
find kind of real disturbing
you know devil's rejects house of a
thousand corpses kind of had that same
tone when i first saw them it was very
disturbing so
back in the day when this movie came out
i would have seen it
i would have thought it was kind of
funny but i've also
would have been pretty disturbed by it
like it would have stuck in the back of
my mind i've been thinking about that
damn imagine if
because the underground [ __ ] lair
underneath that where where all the
cannibals lived
where the sawyer family went yeah where
all the skeletons and the [ __ ] that they
were doing and everything underneath
there it was like something out of
the house with a thousand corpses and
even that movie kind of disturbed me for
a while well as i said you can tell rob
zombie was like a huge huge fan
of this movie yeah because this is kind
of where he got the
the tone from i guess you know i like
the first one
um but i like the second one a lot
better now that i've seen
it uh i think it's a better movie i
would not say that
but they're very different movies like i
said visually it's a much better movie
it looks cool i really really like like
the whole production design of the
underground layer the background layer
the way everything looks
that's super cool the edit uh the script
uh the the story how it moves forward i
think it's a better movie
but you know what i mean it's you know
cinema
is uh you know has a lot to do with the
objective subjective you know to me this
is a lot better movie
yeah well like i said it's i i don't
know i i like horror comics because i
would call this a horror comedy it's
like a black comedy
yeah essentially um which in the way
that a house of a thousand corpses is a
horror comedy
well yeah well i thought that was funny
too yeah but
in a [ __ ] up way yeah it disturbed me
the fact that they were all that
that you're supposed to think what
they're doing is funny yeah
and they think it's funny this [ __ ]
ain't funny you know what i mean
not really well if if [ __ ] like that is
done right
yeah it kind of makes you like it's
funny but then it makes you feel bad
[Laughter]
yeah this one kind of has a little bit
of that too yeah they're keeping dead
bodies around and stuff and [ __ ]
talking to dead bodies because they know
the person just weird [ __ ]
so yeah dead bodies yeah so what ended
up happening with this movie um
so toby hooper as i said very famously
had done
um you know he'd done the original texas
chainsaw massacre that kind of made his
name in horror
even if he never made anything else i
mean i'm sure that would just have
cemented his legacy
he'd also done some other things like
the fun house which we reviewed on there
like that movie so then he got a three
picture deal
with canon films and if you know
anything about 80s cinema canon films uh
golan and globus very very
uh famous for doing mostly action movies
they did like
sylvester stallone [ __ ] like cobra um
you know
a lot of the chuck norris movies the
missing in action movies like all those
kind of
movies yeah so they gave toby hooper
a three picture deal so i think the
first movie that he did
was life force which we also did a movie
respective on i [ __ ] love
life force and i think it's really
underrated space vampires you know i
lied to cobra
yeah at the time cobra came out with
with uh stallone
i thought it kind of sucked saw it again
recently now it kind of aged well
sometimes they're better like when you
see them many years ago yeah yeah
yeah there wasn't a lot to it at the
time but you see it now because now it's
kind of cool
yeah yeah but yeah so he makes life
force um
it doesn't make any money so then he did
uh he did the remake of invaders from
mars which actually
i think i saw it back in the day i don't
i remember it being okay but i don't
remember it making much of an impression
um also that one didn't do very well
so finally for his third one they're
like dude um please make a movie that'll
make some money
so he's like i got an idea i'm gonna do
a sequel to texas chainsaw massacre but
i'm gonna go in a completely different
direction
than the original and also and make it
kind of a parody or a comedy or
something like that
because he didn't want to do the same
thing again
and this one did end up making money not
that much it only cost about four or
four and a half million to make and it
made eight million
so i did not great but it did make a
little bit of a profit i didn't know he
made that invaders from mars
he did remake i remember liking it i
haven't seen it in a long time so i
can't really judge i want to see it i
got to see it i remember seeing it and i
don't really remember much about it
but maybe if i saw it now it would make
like a bigger i remember thinking it was
just
kind of had that cool kind of 80s vibe
yeah
yeah i mean kind of like an evil version
of e.t
yeah and evil e.t i mean that's always
kind of like a good there
there was a kid involved and he knew
about where the martians were and they
were taking over people's parents and
stuff
yeah that's right okay now it's kind of
coming back and then they had the damn
now it's coming back yeah i'll have to
watch that martian i think was inside
his head was inside a crystal ball or
something or tentacles on it looking
weird
yeah i kind of feel like i don't want to
get it confused with mars attacks but
you know what i mean yeah i think they
were taking over didn't they take over
the dog
too they would turn people into like
robots i got to see that [ __ ] again
though see like i said you might be you
might be getting some stuff confused
with mars attacks because i think i get
because some of the imagery in it is
kind of similar yeah yeah
or at least that's how i remember liking
it back in the days thinking it was a
trip they played on hbo all the time
yeah
so uh so finally for toby hooper's last
film for canon he
decided to do this one now as i said
this came out in 1986 and it was kind of
as i said a little divisive among horror
fans because i kind of feel like
it had been such a long time since the
original uh you know it had been like
what was it 12 years because i guess the
original came out in 74.
and um they're like oh well we wanted it
to be like more the same they wanted
kind of because the original texas
chainsaw massacre obviously you know
everyone's seen it but it's kind of more
like a documentary feel it's much more
realistic
not much gore all the gore was implied
even though people remember it being
gory
this one uh much much much
gorier much gorier although
interestingly as i said i saw this when
i was a teenager at a slumber party
and i remember like sitting there
watching it with my friends and stuff
and we were just like whoa
so gross and stuff like that but
watching it recently i'm like oh that's
not as gory is that remembered
i'm just jaded i guess it's over the top
gore yeah it's kind of cartoonish
cutting tops people's heads off the
chainsaws and then
you know the person's still trying to
drive cars you know i mean it's gory but
it's not like it's not believable
yeah it just looks cool and tom savini
did the yeah did the facts
i think probably my favorite effect is
that like you said like near the
beginning where that guy gets the top of
his head off we'll
cut his cut off of the chains always
driving the only the the only gory part
that i remembered
was when uh dennis hopper which will get
it visited
when he kicks that that part of the wall
out and then like all the guts fall out
yeah and also stretch wearing her
friend's face i remember that
but yeah so this is like much much
gorier so uh
so yeah so the story behind this one is
that there's like an opening crawl at
the beginning
so this is set 13 years after the events
of the original texas chainsaw massacre
but i guess it's been covered up by the
authorities
you know what i mean because you know at
the end of the first movie obviously
sally hardesty escaped
and so they're trying to keep it on the
down low that there's like this roving
family of cannibals like in texas like
they couldn't find the house where she
said it
yeah they just couldn't find because i
guess they bugged out yeah
so the implication being that they've
been kind of moving around texas and the
authorities like think they're almost
like an urban legend at this point
so um however the character of uh
lefty who is a he's a texas ranger yeah
uh
yeah or something like that yeah he's
played by dennis hopper
and he is supposed to be i think the
uncle
of sally and franklin from the first
maybe franklin the wheelchair guy
so he uh knows that these cannibals are
real and he's like trying to find them
i had never seen this movie and um you
know i like dennis hopper but i think
this is one of dennis hopper's best
roles
he he just plays a a fun character
and he does crazy [ __ ] i mean he leans
into the crazy
this texas arrangement is hell bent on
[ __ ] finding out what happened to his uh
his relatives
and to bring these damn cannibals to
justice
and once he finds their lair and
everything man it's [ __ ] great i'm
breaking it all down oh now he just
basically runs around all day
cutting with his chainsaws he's got his
style with all his chainsaws
and he's cutting down all the little i'm
the lord of the harvest
yeah yeah all the wooden
poles that uh pillars that hold up this
damn layer that they're in and it's it's
a visual sight i think they they really
you know i mean they took it to a new
level i love that layer it wasn't a
house
it was an underground layer underneath
an old roadside attraction yeah
called what was it called texas land or
texas battle battle texas battle lane
battle catalan something like that [ __ ]
like that it's got all these big fake
mountains and [ __ ] it's got a cowboys
and indians
[ __ ] kind of uh and and mexican
kind of a motif going on you know where
it's all kind of coming together in a
big old damn war
you know and it's abandoned and they're
living underneath it
and they've got it all customized yeah
like in all these tunnels and there was
kind of like an element of water park
too wouldn't it
because a little bit there were like a
lot of shoots and stuff i guess there
was train tracks that went through those
shoots at one time the tracks yeah maybe
that's what it was because we were
sitting there watching like that looks
like it was almost a real place but yeah
i think it might have been a
real place i don't think they'd have
built all that for a movie you wouldn't
think i think it was an abandoned place
but
and i think that the train tracks to the
roller coaster was gone i'm not sure it
was a roller coaster i think what it was
is it was something kind of like
the like that ride in disneyland the
gold rush where it was sh
it was shoots filled with water and you
had the rafts going down yeah yeah i
think that's what it was
something like that yeah but yeah so you
have dennis hopper's character
who kind of comes into this town and uh
you know chasing these people
and these people the sawyer family
pretty much the only
um member of you know the or the same
actor
is the guy that plays uh you know like
the dad character whoever
um you know the one with the uh that
makes the chili
out of people's uh you know yeah out of
human meat which is kind of like
kind of like motel hell but yeah but
motel hell ripped off the original texas
chainsaw massacre so you know
turnabout's very good
yeah yeah that's true that's true yeah
they make side cash by selling them
human
chili yeah and he wins awards he wins
every year he wins wins awards
and he he's the only fan member in the
family that can kind of go out into
public the rest of them are all just too
[ __ ] freaky
one dude well i think it's his son right
the one the metal plate and his head
i'm not sure if it's supposed to be his
i guess it's his son or his nephew's not
real
clear i think there's a bunch of
inbreeding going on in the family too
yeah i guess maybe it could be his son
and his nephew it's the same yeah he's
the dude from house of thousand choruses
yeah bill mosley yeah
that guy bill mosley is anything yeah
okay yeah he's real young and
he's got this exposed metal plate that
he got in vietnam and he's just
[ __ ] up and uh he's constantly itching
and scratching and eating little pieces
of his scalp
and i think there was sin breeding
before he [ __ ] went to vietnam but he
was trying to turn
his amusement park into vietnam land
[Laughter]
talk about going back to the va to have
his [ __ ] plate replaced and there's
all kinds of weird [ __ ]
well he's supposed to be the twin
brother
of the hitchhiker from the original
movie okay you know what i'm saying
because interestingly bill mosley yeah
yeah that's right bill moseley
yeah he got run over by a truck at the
end okay and actually the body that he's
carrying around with him is supposed to
be the body of that guy okay it's
supposed to be the run over
hitchhikers run over twin yeah all right
yeah they're carrying around their dead
ancestors
yeah and some of them you can't figure
you find out they're not dead they're
actually alive but they're sold they
don't move
and either well like i said that that
was kind of that was kind of like the
first movie where grandpa came out and
he was yeah they look like corpses but
200 years old or whatever i think in
this one they said grandpa was a hundred
and thirty they feed them
all liquid diet from [ __ ] human
extract that keeps them alive you're
good electric in like a state of near
death
yeah and then uh all kinds of and then
you got leatherface there and he's
wearing
another another [ __ ] rotten preserved
body on the front of him so it's like
somebody else is doing it i didn't
really catch
i don't i don't know if that was an
ancestor who he was making it look like
the ancestor was
wheeling the chainsaw i don't know it's
like he had double disguises because he
also was wearing someone else's face
yeah and then he was also wearing
another body on top of them
it was just so he's like doubly
disguised
leatherface thinking unfortunately they
couldn't get gunner hanson back to play
leather fans in this one
um so as i said you know so bill mosley
i was going to say how he got this role
this might have been his first movie
role like
i think he was in a couple little movies
before this but this was like his first
major one
he actually got this part i think he
didn't even have to audition for it
because
him and his i think his wife or his
girlfriend at the time they had made a
parody of the texas chainsaw massacre
called the texas chainsaw manicure
and he had played like a hitchhiker type
character
and so when they wanted to redo the
movie and they're like okay we're gonna
have like the twin brother of that guy
you play him so it's kind of like
channel that guy so that's how he ended
up getting the part
because he was in like a parody film of
it that he had made like a little
independent one
you know yeah but um yeah so you have
that
and then you have so there's the three
of them are kind of like the main
deal and like you said like the dad dude
he's like the only one that goes out and
he makes chili and whatnot
now you also have the other main
character being the radio dj
stretch yeah she got some fantastic legs
stretched she run around all day long
with his legs stretched out those cut
off shorts
that's what they're doing as i
understand it yeah i understand what
they're what they're talking about
she gets involved because she's working
at this little dinky ass radio station
and there's these two at the very
beginning there's these two like kind of
yuppie douchebags and they're driving
into town because they're supposedly
like this big football game like a
college football game or whatever
and they keep like calling her because
they're listening to the radio and they
keep calling her
with their car phone i was like 1986.
yeah carphone in 1986 you had to be
super rich that was like some pretty
high-tech [ __ ] it's like a thousand
dollars a month and it was it wasn't
cordless obviously it was just kind of
and it wasn't one of those big brick
ones but it was like radio transmitter
in the damn vehicle
yeah yeah to do it so only like a vapor
high to high
and yuppies and it was like a thousand
dollars a month yeah it was something
for the service
yeah ridiculous because not a lot of
people had it it was just like wealthy
people just just super rich people
yeah so they have so they have that and
they're driving into town they decide
they're gonna
call this poor radio dj and like harass
her and it so happens that while they're
on the phone harassing her
they um get into the game of chicken
right with a truck
which they don't know at the time but
contains members of the sawyer family
and then later on that night the you
know the sawyer family comes back
leatherface is up on the roof wearing
the face and wearing the other body
and he pretty much like chainsaws
through the top of the car and cuts that
dude's head off
and so stretch gets the whole murder
on tape you know what i mean like the
audio tape yeah
so um so that's i think that's kind of
what brings
dennis hopper there because it looked
like the the cops were like no no it was
just an accident
and dennis hopper's like yeah i don't
think you can chainsaw off your own head
like and then like that makes you crash
your car so him and stretch kind of join
forces
to like go after so it's pretty much the
first half of the movie
is the two of them getting together and
then you have
bill moseley's character who kind of who
comes in there
like uh into the radio station and
starts like harassing her
and then kills or takes the um the other
guy that works at the radio station
right and like drags him back to the
lair and then her and dennis hopper end
up having to like
you know chase them to the lair and then
she gets trapped in there and running
around
and all this other kind of stuff so
pretty much like the second half of the
movie
is down in the lair there's also another
dinner scene they do another dinner
scene pretty much exactly like the first
movie but with her instead of i [ __ ]
up not seeing it
you did this like i said this sounds
exactly like something you would like
yeah i didn't know that i hadn't seen it
nobody brought it up i guess it i guess
it came out
after i had graduated graduated from
high school so it wasn't one that we got
at blockbuster
maybe i mean it's 86 that came out i
know okay then it would have been
first maybe blockbuster didn't carry it
or something maybe
i i don't i never saw it that's really
yeah like i said that seems like this
seems exactly like one yeah in the right
time that the time frame was correct
yeah i should have seen it but no i
never saw it for whatever reason i
hadn't seen this one like i said since i
was a teenager
but for whatever reason i was thinking
that this was the one that had matthew
mcconaughey and renee zellweger in it
but it
wasn't that was the fourth one i think
like checks his chainsaw the next
generation
i put it right there with uh the evil
dead movies
uh i put it right there with the uh
jeffrey combs
[ __ ] lovecraft movies um
let me see what else i put it right
there with uh
you know like hellraiser stuff but
yeah but like towards the top of that
pile
yeah i mean this one it's super fun yeah
it's just a fun
gory like i said if you want something
that's more like the first one
kind of like that real serious uh you
know documentary tone
you know what i heard is that toby
hooper he wanted to make the first texas
chainsaw massacre
more like this one i guess like that was
his original vision for it was it was
supposed to be more like he was able to
do it a parody or more like
funny he wanted to make like a black
comedy and he still says that the
original well he
still doesn't say it now because he
passed away sadly but um he said for a
long time that
the original texas chainsaw massacre had
a lot of black comedy elements in it
which i guess it sort of does but it
doesn't translate as much
i guess it's this one so this almost
seems like this is what he wanted to do
if you don't know any of those old
movies that we grew up with but you like
house of a thousand corpses and
um and devil's rejects this is like the
prequels
it is kind of like that yeah it feels
like a prequel to that yeah as
it's real over the top it has like this
real strange like
carnival-esque atmosphere like all the
characters are just
super ridiculous and super over the top
i mean
kind of tone yeah and it's just you know
when everyone's just like screaming and
you know what i mean it's that kind of
thing dennis hopper
one of the funniest scenes in this for
me just made me laugh and laugh was the
scene where dennis hopper
goes to the chainsaw store which is
funny it's like a convenience store and
then a chainsaw store because you know
that's just how you do it's texas
um and he buys three chainsaws
without and there's like no talking like
between him
and the old guy that runs the the shop
but it's just like the
i don't know just like the edits and the
facial expressions like between them and
like
i don't know something about it like
just really cracked me up and it cracked
me up that there's no dialogue in it
that he just comes in and buys these
[ __ ] three
and then he goes out and just like goes
ham on this [ __ ]
log out there or whatever you know
what's funny is you were saying you
think this is one of dennis miller
dennis miller dennis dennis hopper's
best roles
um it's funny because he said later i
don't know if he still
you know thought this uh later but he
was just like he thought this was like
the worst movie he'd ever
done and i was like dude you were in the
mario brothers like the super mario
brothers movie
like he played king koopa right with
john
i was like i think that might be the
worst movie you're in
wonder why i think this is the worst
movie i don't know it's it's just funny
because
it stands out it really does and it's
almost kind of like you know
frank booth and uh blue velvet which you
know another kind of role that he played
this one he's kind of like that in this
one
he's just like plays a completely crazy
person
i don't think he really understood the
tone maybe not
i don't know a lot of people didn't
respect horror at the time that's true
it was the 80s and you know he
wasn't he was an apocalypse now he was
in a lot of great [ __ ] movies
yeah maybe in comparison to some of the
great movies this was not a high brow
movie
but in terms of its genre this is a
great movie yeah
this is a great movie i mean if you love
like 80s [ __ ] like return of the living
dead or
you know the evil dead just these just
over the top crazy fun
wacky gory the movie is exactly what
it's supposed to be i can't tell that
there's no mistakes in the movie this is
what they wanted
and i i agree with all the decisions
all the creative decisions everything in
the damn editing the dialogue
the [ __ ] score and the soundtrack of
the music also the soundtrack to this
i'm glad
you mentioned that because i really want
to mention that soundtrack for this
kicks app yes
i put it up there with like uh horror
masterpieces with like you know house
with a thousand corpses and devil's
rejects i mean this could be the prequel
you could really see that
those two movies were in a way kind of
like not knockoffs but continuations of
this theme in this tone
yeah it's pretty much exactly so that's
the prequel
yeah if you like those movies and you
didn't you've never seen this one
go back and watch this you'll love it
you'll you'll see where all that stuff
came from
you know doc what's his name dr satan
there's all kinds of [ __ ] like that in
there just surprise characters that come
out of nowhere like what the [ __ ] is
that
yeah yeah there's a lot of what the [ __ ]
did i just watch yeah yeah
in this movie particularly the very very
famous scene of leatherface
um kind of putting the chainsaw into
stretch's crotch while she's yeah
well she's trying to like convince him
that she's not don't do it don't do it
yeah
you're not mad at me you're not backing
me
well that was playing right now they're
weird that was playing right into the
tropes of the time
yeah when we were renting this kind of
these kind of movies back in high school
it was about over the top [ __ ] wacky
violence
horror that made you uncomfortable and
sex sex sex really just sexy ass women
yeah that was kind of like the girl from
what was her name lorena
uh she what was that what what's that uh
okay the girl from uh from beyond one
she's nearly got getting [ __ ] naked
oh yeah
yeah yeah what's that girl's name i
gotcha yeah i
night and then was it return of the
living dead or was it yeah she was in
return living dead yeah
you always we're gonna see some somebody
like that in it
in the movie yeah we expected to see
that
and this character she never gets nude
but she's
she kind of had to fulfill that trope
of the sexy damsel in distress who makes
it
although she's pretty kick-ass and
though she's kick-ass yeah yeah she's
not she's
distressed but she fights back she holds
her own yeah yeah she's not just she
doesn't just sit there
she gets captured a couple times yeah
but she gets out yeah so she is a damsel
in distress she is waiting for her dude
to save her but he never saved her
no he didn't she said she had his own
agenda she saved herself
so and he just went off in la la land so
he was just like you know what i mean
dennis hopper i mean how many times are
you going to say this movie is the only
movie in
creation that has dennis hopper
with three chainsaws yeah with in a
chainsaw deal with leatherface
yeah i mean come on so she did fulfill
the damsel in distress
role yeah yeah okay but the thing is is
that she ended up saving herself
yeah all right and and that which i
guess you could say
was not really a that was also a common
trope even back in these days like you
hear people
today saying oh those old movies they
were you know they were so sexist the
women were not empowered
no they were always empowered well i
think they were always saving themselves
that first started in the 80s actually
in the latter movies
i do kind of feel like 50s wasn't like
that no yeah 50s and 60s
uh well the movie not that much you
started to see some of that though a
little bit
i spit on what that was that was 17 that
was early 70s okay that was 72 73
okay um yeah that well that's like the
whole yeah the whole rape revenge
genre yeah it was you know there were
there were
you know examples of it but i do kind of
feel like
i feel like the whole because the whole
final girl trope and everything like
that that sort of came into its own in
the 80s i feel like maybe late set
well i guess late 70s because yeah like
halloween in our lifetimes
the women always did well they they
yeah people were trying to save them but
they in the end kind of saved themselves
yeah because i mean yeah they they had
to be killed they had to be uh
resourceful
yeah usually what would happen it was
like a success an acceptable storyline
uh to a teenage boy who was the
marketing that was you know is that
the guy who he can identify with is
trying to save her through the whole
thing he can't get to her
he finally is able to get to her they're
together for a little bit but then he
dies defending her and then she get then
she gets away
yeah or then she ends up saving herself
yeah
and then like you know on friday the
13th then jason comes up out of the
water and grabs her but
but you don't know but it really
happened
you know because who was what about the
little boy you know that kind of [ __ ] so
you don't know if it really happened
don't worry too much about continuity
yeah the 13th movies and honestly don't
worry too much about continuity with the
texas chainsaw massacre movies either
because
especially after this one this one does
have ties in like it's supposed they're
supposed to be relatives of
you know the victims and the family from
the first one and they do have some
but after this it just went what they
just went whatever they just kind of
like oh we're going to reboot it or
this is like in the they just like
[ __ ] went off in its own direction
i wanted to say too when we were talking
about the
uh the soundtrack is i had forgotten how
[ __ ] rad the soundtrack for this was
it has uh the cramps it has lords of the
new church yeah
it has oingo boingo yeah uh it had
concrete blonde
um just all kind of like rocky erickson
all kind of really really cool
[ __ ] and then just the score the the
music that's it
was just real good and all the the audio
cues the soundscapes up
it was all it was all good the lighting
was [ __ ] really good
set design super good um i loved all the
christmas lights
with all the because they had all the
dead body [ __ ] like but it was yeah but
there was
uh it was like a massive massive area
you know what i mean that they had to
decorate well even outside the lair too
you know what i mean yeah get up on the
surface it looked great uh
the nighttime shots just everything the
outdoor shots everything was good the
shots of the uh of the radio station
looked great
the old neons neon [ __ ] um neon
clocks and stuff on the inside
you know and it was just kind of
nostalgic to see all that
and then they had uh what is it remember
how they had all the uh
shelves and shelves of record albums
yeah when's the last time you've seen
that
i know that was very that was pretty
cool it brought a lot of [ __ ] back and
how much
how much room all that stuff took up the
whole building was
taken up with record albums you don't
see that anymore yeah
keep that on mp3 player now yeah back in
the old days
you had to have all the physical space
right yeah you know what's funny to me
is that when this movie first came
out in 86 um they were going to the npa
wanted to give an x rating because it
was too gory
but uh toby hooper said no i'm not going
to cut anything so they
release it unrated it's just funny
that's why i couldn't get it at them
maybe probably yeah they wouldn't do
anything that was unrated yeah they
wouldn't run out what it was
that's why we never saw it i mean we saw
it because we didn't run it for
blockbuster we ran it from somewhere
else
like a mom-and-pop place but um yeah
that would probably explain it why you
didn't see it yeah because they didn't
you know they they would have had to cut
it which is like really funny because if
you watch it
nowadays it's gory but it's not
i mean we've nowadays we've seen way
[ __ ] worse
yeah and back in the day back in the day
you know we didn't have internet
so we would have probably known that
there was a texas chainsaw mask or two
but that wouldn't have meant anything to
us yeah because the first one was just
it was okay but you didn't have to see
the second one
you know what i mean so it wasn't a
cultural phenomenon back then we didn't
even know about it
yeah i don't remember even talking about
it well as i said we know we had to
watch the [ __ ] out of it yeah
we would have liked it it did okay at
the box office like it made a profit
unlike the other two movies that toby
hooper had made for canon
but it didn't make a [ __ ] ton of money
i feel like it only got um it got a cult
following later like after it came out
on video
like a lot of people didn't go see it at
the theater like didn't bother because
like i said it had been such a long time
since the first one had come out so i
kind of feel like people were just like
man we don't need more of that
but um yeah so i feel like as time went
on
as i said it when it first came out it
was real like some horror fans were like
oh they didn't like it because it's just
like completely completely
different than the first one but then
that but then there was like the other
half of horror fans were like no that's
exactly why we like it because toby
hooper decided to just go in a
completely different direction instead
of
retreading the same stuff and i feel
like appreciation for it has kind of
grown
over the years i tell you what i can
guarantee you had we seen trailers for
it we would have wanted to see it we'd
have found it
but yeah just weren't really aware of it
i mean we i i can i can remember that we
knew it existed but that didn't mean
anything to us
yeah that's true there were other movies
to watch if we didn't we just rented the
ones that we would find
yeah at the at the uh at blockbuster or
any of the other rental places and i
guess like i guess because it was on
rated
they wouldn't they wouldn't if i'm
remembering correctly blockbuster
wouldn't rent anything that was
unrated or nc 17 or anything like that
they would do r
obviously but nothing like work like
worse than that
if you wanted something unrated or nc 17
yeah someplace else and get it
that's weird because it's just kind of
like walmart wouldn't sell them if it
was over an r
that's weird because uh we we ran it
from beyond
and we rented you know what i mean and
that had that was
pretty wild i would if that was an r
though that was an r
yeah i don't really see the difference
between this and that in terms of that's
what i mean in hindsight
yeah you know yeah this movie's gory but
it's not
not really that big i mean compared to
some other [ __ ]
compared to something like that came out
let's compare it to something that came
out in the 80s like dead alive
this is way not as gorgeous and what was
weird about that time is that
you can get around those ratings and
maybe i'm just not really remembering
how things were shot
like you could you could pull tricks
instead of making the blood red you made
it green and you could do anything you
wanted as long as it was green
yeah and i think there's a lot i think a
lot of movies
are [ __ ] stupid and a lot of movies
so arbitrary a lot of movies were able
to get those r ratings by using blood
that wasn't the right color well
it's green because that's a zombie yeah
or that's not here it's an alien or
something
it's it's a demon yeah
or that person was possessed by the
demons so the blue the
the blood's blue or it's black yeah so
that's how it got around a lot of that
[ __ ] but you didn't notice it
right because that's just some technical
detail that you didn't you know the
impression was still the same yeah it
got cut off the [ __ ] blood went
flying
blood was black but you didn't even
really hardly notice it yeah
yeah i kind of feel like well tom savini
who did the effects on this if i didn't
mention it
i do kind of feel like he kind of ran
into this problem a lot because you know
tom savini
was in nam he was a photographer and um
so he would have to go around and take
pictures of all the
dead bodies and everything so uh he got
very well known for his
special effects being super realistic
and
so i think that that got him into a lot
of so they ended up cutting a lot of his
effects just because they looked too
real i'd have to go back and look at
those
those lovecraft movies and how much you
want to bet that a lot of times
that the blood was off color yeah or
maybe
because that was more in a fantasy yeah
it's more of a face
because i feel like you can get away
with more if you're doing something in a
fantastical
setting so maybe that's how they got
around it and we just didn't really
notice it
because i remember the gore being about
the same yeah
but they must have been playing on some
kind but as i said this was more of like
realistic
it was like realistic looking corpses
you know there's one thing where
dennis hopper shoves the chainsaw all
the way through leatherface's stomach
yeah you know there's just like there's
a whole big thing full of
um you know at one point uh leatherface
peels
all the the skin off of um the other guy
that works at the radio station peels
his face off
and then he's kind of like falling in
love with stretch i guess
so he's attempting to disguise her
he's just like here put this face and
she's like oh please please don't put my
best friend's face out of my face that's
so nasty
but he was just like trying to be nice
because he thought that was gonna hide
her and i was like oh
that's so sad i put the face on the
cowboy hat
and then i like that he that the skin
dude is like still alive
and then um at one i like i love that
his last words are oh
[ __ ] and then he dies and then she put
his face back on
him like it looks so bad and it's just
kind of like it's cool
there you go yeah but this is a really
really
fun movie this is definitely like you
know get a pizza
get some beers get some of your buddies
to come over it's on shutter at the
moment and i think it also might be on
pluto tv
for free or to be or something but uh
shutter just added it not too long ago i
was very excited because i've been
wanting to do this for a really long
time and i thought you had seen it no
because it definitely is something one
of the best movies in that era
yeah definitely something that you would
like but yeah that's horror movies of
that area if you just love like gory
over the top
just crazy funny batshit crazy stuff
then yeah you definitely need to see
this like i said it's nothing like the
first movie so don't expect it to be
but it's super fun nonetheless so uh
yeah check it out
all right so that'll do it for this
discussion we will see you on the next
one
bye
you